al tragar la comida esta deja la boca y
va al esófago enfoquémonos en eso todos
sabemos qué tan lejos llega el esófago y
para asegurarme voy a dibujar algunas
líneas para mostrar dónde comienza aquí
y luego termina justo por aquí y donde
dibuje las líneas también hay esfínteres
para asegurar que la comida fluya solo
en un sentido aquí arriba tenemos el
esfínter esofágico superior esfínter
esofágico y sólo para reiterar un
esfínter es una localización circular
del músculo es un montón de músculos en
forma de anillo justo aquí eso asegura
que esté cerrado a menos que le digamos
que se relaje para pasar la comida y
cuando digo que vamos a decirle al
músculo que se relaje implica entonces
que este músculo está bajo nuestro
control por lo tanto se compone
principalmente de músculo esquelético
músculo esquelético que está bajo
control voluntario y aquí abajo tenemos
el esfínter esofágico inferior esto es
un poco complicado porque lo llamamos
esfínter y ya saben
el esfínter parece un esfínter pero en
realidad no funciona como un esfínter
supongo que es una broma científica si
quieren llamarlo así porque aquí no
tenemos un anillo muscular que se abre y
se cierra cada vez que nuestro cuerpo lo
considere apropiado que tenemos en su
lugar bueno en realidad tenemos una hoja
justo aquí es una capa muscular que
alinea la conexión entre la cavidad
torácica y la cavidad abdominal entonces
pueden imaginar que tienen una cavidad
torácica aquí arriba y hay cosas que
están aquí como los pulmones y el
corazón y abajo tenemos una cavidad
abdominal la cavidad abdominal que
tendrá la mayor parte del tracto
gastrointestinal y este músculo que
tenemos aquí es el diafragma
probablemente hayas oído hablar de él es
un músculo esquelético voluntario que se
contrae para tirar hacia abajo y
ayudarnos a respirar cuando se mueve
hacia abajo los pulmones se inflan con
aire entonces el diafragma que está aquí
en realidad hace un anillo alrededor de
este esfínter esofágico inferior
fragma en realidad es el esfínter
esofágico inferior porque simplemente
está allí sosteniendo el esófago en su
lugar y es por eso que con el tiempo
podemos tener lo que se llama una hernia
hiatal el esófago puede moverse hacia
arriba y hacia abajo a través de este es
interés o fagic o inferior y tendremos
ácido gástrico del estómago que refluye
hacia arriba y que nos provoca acidez
estomacal o enfermedad por reflujo
gastroesofágico hereje por eso nosotros
tenemos acidez estomacal pero los
roedores y los caballos no lo tienen
ellos tienen un verdadero esfínter aquí
tienen un anillo dedicado de músculo en
lugar de una capa ahora la otra cosa
sobre el esófago que resulta bastante
interesante es que funciona como un
pasaje para la comida no hace mucho más
el único proceso en el que podemos
afirmar que tiene alguna participación
es el que se conoce como peris tal sis
peris tal sis y ese será un término
importante para la discusión del resto
del tracto gastrointestinal la peristas
is es sólo la propulsión ondulatoria de
los
alimentos propulsión ondulatoria solo
escribir eso por ahora porque tendremos
la contracción del esófago en este punto
de arriba y al hacer eso se relaja aquí
abajo y cuando se relaja aquí se contrae
aquí significa que si tienes un bolo de
comida como este pequeño círculo que
tenemos aquí tiende a moverse de esta
manera directamente hacia adelante y eso
es feris tall sis y la forma en que
controlamos eso a lo largo del esófago
es en tres partes porque el esófago no
es solo músculo esquelético a lo largo
de todo el camino o no solo es músculo
liso se divide en tercios
así que dibujaré tres partes del esófago
la primera parte que tenemos en realidad
es solo músculo esquelético que está
bajo nuestro control voluntario músculo
esquelético y eso es un tercio un tercio
superior del esófago aquí en medio en
realidad tenemos una mezcla tenemos
músculo esquelético bajo nuestro control
más músculo liso y trabajan juntos por
lo tanto están bajo nuestro control pero
en realidad no tanto
será el tercio medio del esófago un
tercio medio y mientras avanza
finalmente llegamos al último tercio del
esófago que va a ser músculo liso así
que este es nuestro último tercio y así
es como el esófago se divide en tres
partes esquelético en el tercio superior
esquelético y liso en el tercio medio y
luego totalmente liso en el último
tercio y así es como funciona nuestro
esófago